the country may be at a crucial point
this morning in the corona virus
pandemic with cases rising again and
officials deciding whether to stay the
course on reopening at least 19 states
think about that for a second nineteen
states have seen new cases go up in just
the last two weeks Anthony that's right
Gail and six states reported record
increases yesterday that includes nearly
2,400 new cases in Arizona more than
2,600 in Texas and nearly 2800 new cases
in Florida but there is also some
possible good news when it comes to
treating the virus Manuel Bojorquez is
following all this from Miami many a lot
of people are getting sick what are
officials saying well good morning
Anthony Florida Governor Ron de Santos
said Tuesday the case spikes are due to
increase testing especially in high-risk
areas like nursing homes and farming
communities he did acknowledge community
spread is happening but the state's
reopening plan is not changing you do
now have widespread testing of
asymptomatic people Tuesday Florida
Governor Ron de santis dismissed
concerns reopening czar driving
Florida's record-breaking run of new
coronavirus cases the restaurants have
been doing this for what have they been
doing it for for six weeks I mean the
idea that that all of a sudden is the
reason I'm not sure that that's but
that's the case so no we're not shutting
down
but bars in several cities have started
closing on their ownafter workers and
patrons tested positive for the virus
including Lynch's pub in Jacksonville
seven of its 49 employees tested
positive so did Erica crisp and ten of
her friends after going there for drinks
they've all been stuck in doors for
months
being careful social distancing doing
everything the right way and then the
first night would go out Murphy's Law I
guess a similar phenomenon is happening
as bars reopen in Texas according to
governor Greg Abbott who threatened to
suspend liquor licenses for restaurants
violating reopening rules there are
certain counties where a majority of the
people who were tested positive in that
we are under the age of 30 and this
typically results from people going to
bar type settings but some good news
Tuesday a potential breakthrough has
emerged in the fight against the virus
and what we saw was really quite
remarkable scientists in the United
Kingdom said that a cheap decades-old
steroid called dexamethasone reduced
deaths in kovat 19 patients on oxygen by
20% and reduced death by 35% for
patients on ventilators this is really
good news CBS News chief medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook says while
the findings still need to be published
and peer-reviewed the initial reports
are promising one of the nice things
here is that there was a relatively
large number of patients studied for
several months and so the fact that
they're saying there was a statistically
significant decrease in mortality with
dexamethasone is very encouraging the
mayors of nine Texas cities sent a
letter to Governor Greg Abbott urging
him to grant them the authority to
enforce mask-wearing in public an
executive order by the governor
prohibits local governments from
imposing fees or criminal penalties for
not wearing a mask in public we reached
out to the governor's office but have
not yet heard back Tony
very interesting many of course the
governor said many of the cases are
people under the age of 30 they may be
fine personally but the worry is they'll
go and visit somebody who will not be
fine that's the concern Manny thank you
very much